this video is brought to you by private
internet access vpn
as i absent-mindedly scrolled through
twitter the other week i stumbled across
something that shook me
to my very core a revelation so haunting
that i had to step away from my phone
and take a break super dragon ball
heroes
yes that has been on the air for longer
than dragon ball super
what what
what holy [ __ ] why are we still here
i know right although dramatically
shorter in runtime heroes has been on
the air for 36 months compared to
super's 32 months
and i'm not sure how to process this did
i fall into the void and lose years of
my life did the apocalypse happen and i
woke
up in another dimension is dragon ball
heroes a loki variant i have many
questions but to get to the bottom of
this mystery we have to henceforth march
forward onto the brink my friends
oh my that's right 14 months after our
last venture we're diving back into the
bonkers the bizarre and apparently time
traveling world of super dragon ball
heroes
episode 21 ah there it is the breakneck
logic defying pace that this show
operates within
it's almost like this show has no
interest in plot well okay
almost it does technically care about it
it just tries to get through it as fast
as possible we learn who we're following
what the problem is who's been involved
in all of this
and what we'll be focusing on in the
space off and i kid you not
about a minute i swear it felt like i'm
trunks and this is pen and we're after
losing a bird where did it go cut to
earth oh my god check it out there's
this weird looking bird that happened to
appear by us what are the odds enter
pan and trunks exposition
enter gods of destruction i mean what's
happening oh there it is
what is happening the single most common
phrase ordered while watching this show
how i've missed thee they should put on
a shirt super dragon ball
heroes what the [ __ ] is happening but
wait no time for that because beerus is
trying to destroy the bird but then the
bird gets rid of his
hakkai and then pieces out with pan and
so naturally it's time for beerus vs
goku round two
oh and goku screams so loud the weather
changes from sunny to thunder and
lightning in the span of and i kid you
not again
a couple of seconds but just as fast as
it started few shows up and it turns out
he's behind all the confusion
just like last time and he has the evil
version of tokitoki that bird that
beerus was
yeah that guy well the evil version of
that is called doki doki episode 22 goku
vegeta
and trunks vs beerus is really boring
and gets interrupted by
time patrol goku and vegeta who show up
out of nowhere roots take hold of the
different universes leading to the rest
of the gods of destruction to peace out
back to where they came from and
okay get this right few for literally no
reason at all decided to show up in
front of beerus trunks and two sets of
goku and vegeta and decides to show them
that he's behind all of this
and tells them what he intends to do
without this they would have had
literally
no idea and he would have gotten away
with it too
so if you'd like to
forgot this if you're interested in
checking out super dragon ball heroes
for yourself you have
two options the first is watching some
low quality re-upload and the second is
watching via the official source
unfortunately that official source is
locked exclusively to the region of
japan and
these types of country-specific locks
are becoming more and more common across
streaming services
thankfully however there's a simple
solution private internet
access vpn pia offers one of the most
simple to use vpn solutions out there
after a quick install on your pc phone
or tablet you get access to servers in
over 75 countries and with a quick click
of a button
those pesky region locks are going to
vanish leaving you with a wealth of new
content to enjoy the benefits aren't
limited exclusively to streaming
services either
in this day and age your internet
service provider is constantly
monitoring each and every website you
visit
whether you're at home or using your
public wi-fi spots your privacy is at
risk
but thanks to pia once you enable your
vpn service
your data is routed through encrypted
tunnels away from prying eyes even those
at pia themselves so if you'd like to
protect yourself
online today and gain access to some
region exclusive content
simply click the link in the description
and get pia vpn for less than three
dollars a month with two
extra months for free that means like
only two dollars and
eight cents per month and 83 percent off
and with a 30-day money-back guarantee
it's totally
risk-free so give it a try i hope you
find it as useful as i did
this is some of the most clunky
unnecessary and hilariously bad
exposition
i've seen even by hero standards but
look like i said before i'm not
expecting shakespeare from the story it
is an advertisement after all heck
i'm barely anticipating a story so when
i saw that there was a
actual reason a tenuous reason for
beerus to once again get sidelined i was
peeved but at the very least
he's not peacing out for no reason at
all they have at the very least given
him a storied reason
for not participating in the main plot
this time and you know what on a
foundational level
i can get behind that giant patrol goku
and vegeta on the other hand
literally okay they literally show up
and say virtually
nothing of substance they just watch
everything happen and then leave saying
we will do our own investigating well my
work is done here
what do you mean your work is done you
don't do anything
didn't i
[Applause]
oh cool thanks for the contribution guys
maybe in your investigation you can i
don't know find any reason
at all for being there next time also i
love the enthusiasm from trunks when he
says i'll go with you to our goku and
vegeta you know but
okay question am i supposed to know
where the next step in this process will
be where are we going
how exactly is he going to oh never mind
they're powering up and flying towards
the screen on their way to
somewhere episode 23 so foo brings a
bunch of villains from dragon ball's
films and
gt together somehow and turles fights
bojack
it's bad thanks to the power of editing
goku and ko are now out looking for foo
on some random planet by following the
bird can people understand this bird how
do they know to follow it
why do we need colonel sanders in this
episode well the last one's obvious it's
all down to time patrol vegeta and
goku's vague and nondescript
investigations
the other questions i have however i
don't know but what i do know is that
this is a story where the tree huggers
are the bad guys and the tree colors are
the good guys it's very regressive
messaging
nothing much happens in this episode
goku and vegeta fight taurus and bojack
in a very boring combat that uses the
exact same shots over and over and over
again that we've seen before in prior
episodes
episode 24. before i get into this
episode i gotta address something
because of how
short these episodes are the formula
that they use is ridiculously
transparent
think about it every episode ends with
something coming out of nowhere with
great promise for the next episode like
a transformation or new character
entering the fray
seriously that covers like 90 of all
these episodes alone and when the next
episode comes around it's like
gonna deal with this new thing people
were excited for as fast as possible so
that we can get back to the boring parts
of the episode and explore more boring
clunky exposition before once again
ending on something like a
transformation or a character reveal
anyways time for episode 24. so right
after the new character terminator
colonel sanders shows up time patrol
vegeta and goku turns super saiyan 3 and
super saiyan 4 but to no avail
it's honestly a really boring fight
which aside from a few amazing fight
sequences that this side series has been
blessed with it's pretty power for the
course to get an average boring fighting
affair which is a shame considering that
super dragon ball heroes is a property
that relies on style over substance
switching gears for a second to deal
with our goku and vegeta fighting
turtles and bojack the doggy doggy bird
flaps its wings stopping them from
moving
okay few steals tokitaki and they all
peace out once again the scene then cuts
quickly the terminator colonel sanders
arriving
somewhere we don't know where calling
out janemba's name
see what i mean about every episode
being the same they physically can't
hook you with the story so
they just throw nostalgic names at you
and i can't blame them
it must totally work because these
episodes are uploaded on youtube
and get so many views i can see people
watching this shouting at their monitors
and phones like
oh my god that's the guy from the thing
yes
it is the guy from the thing and guess
what every episode is going to have some
guy from something or some
transformation from something
or in the case of this episode both
episode 25. anyways next episode oh my
god it's jin ember she's the guy from
the movie that i like
this is gonna be awesome for some reason
okay like jokes aside i honestly have
absolutely no clue how this even works
or makes sense even in this reality
i mean wasn't janemba originally just
some caretaker from otherworld that got
infected by the fumes from a certain
machine that breaks down
so is this that guy oh wait no
according to colonel sanders over here
it's quote
resurrected genember i'm gonna be honest
dude that makes even less sense
does it mean that this isn't the same
character and if that's the case
then that's not the guy from that thing
that i like and look
i swear i'm not making this up as if by
magic out of virtually nowhere
a tear in space and time opens up
dropping goku trunks and vegeta onto the
battlefield
and it doesn't appear as if anyone on
the battlefield has an answer as to why
this happens in the first place
i guess they just got lucky and don't
really feel like addressing that obvious
deus ex machina the fight continues it's
boring
trunks turns super saiyan 3 again it's
boring and these two
new characters descend from the heavens
called
majin salsa and poutine this is the
dumbest stuff i've ever seen from this
series which means things are going to
get good
episode 26 maximum dumb in this episode
so
everyone decides the best course of
action is to give all their energy to a
version of themselves that they don't
know fully yet and then the two time
patrol saiyans go
limit breakers super saiyan 4 yes you
heard me right
and they then punched janemba real hard
janemba goes bye-bye that's the episode
next
episode 27. every episode seems to have
our characters flashing from one
location to the next without any rhyme
or reason
this would bother me if not for the fact
that the bar is so unbelievably low now
that the concept of plot
seems like an unfair standard to set the
passing grade for super dragon ball
heroes is flashing colors at this point
so what happens in this episode honestly
i have no idea ah fu shows up to speak
vegeta gets mad at the big evil tree foo
is sucking cumber vegeta and goku get
possessed and then they fuse with the
kai earrings that seem to be more
plentiful than the senzu beans in this
universe
if that seems like a lot to cover in
literally five minutes then i guess your
power level is too low to watch super
dragon ball heroes
episode 28 alright jesus uh
okay so there's this girl right she
created foo and using the energy of
cumber restrains the rest of them before
talking about that one guy trunks
defeated in that god-awful special he
did a while back
this is so convoluted and weird and not
in a good way then
this guy shows up i don't really know
his name we'll call him lionface
lionface suddenly appears and drops
super saiyan 4 time patrol goku's two
children in a heap before him
once they collect their dark aura
your guess is as good as mine here they
get cast somewhere through some
dimensional wormhole thing
i hope you're not expecting answers from
me or this show because if you are
you're going to be disappointed vegito
fights foo in a slightly above average
visual display and then the universe
seed is destroyed through a wish from
beerus using the super dragon balls off
screen
yes that actually happens episode 29.
episode 29 of this series is a special
of sorts it's a standalone episode
disconnected from everything we've seen
and it's all the better forward i think
it's still nothing special but
it's a cute advertisement for the game
that this series is encouraging people
to buy into the story shows a young kid
showing up at a shopping center to
compete in the game with another young
girl they get sucked into the game and
all sorts of fighting with all sorts of
different characters takes place
again it's nothing special per se but it
works as a commercial
for this game okay back to the actual
story now
episode 30. so phil gets big mad until
he somehow learns his tragic backstory
and now he's a dark lord with a big
energy cape
i'm not kidding that literally happens
he uses his new powers of contrivance to
restore the tree but wait vegito cuts in
and
wait again super saiyan 4 vegito cuts in
also
appearing from yet another portal in the
sky okay
apparently helped by demigra i've either
no clue who this person is or i've
completely forgotten about them either
way it's hilarious to watch this madness
unfold the episode ends in a more
traditional fashion with a random scene
of broly turning around with glowing
eyes he's never been in this arc so far
so it's par for the course with a new
reveal at the end of every episode this
is
the dumbest show ever and i love it
episode 31
the name of the episode is limit breaker
broly
is resurrected let that sink in so as
food tangos with two vegitos that have
lasted in their respective forms longer
in this instance than the entire series
combined it feels like
suddenly transports them or conjures a
floating fortress in space beneath a big
tree
when broly suddenly attacks remember
this story began with goku playing with
a bird and now it's
i have legitimately no more words to
accurately convey my bewilderment and
shock over how stupid this is
so let's turn to the dictionary this is
inscrutable beyond any measure okay i
feel better
so fu restores the tree to broly's
unheralded and sudden arrival
time to deal with that now i guess
episode 32 so
blue vegito keeps broly busy while super
saiyan 4 vegito fights foo
that's most of the episode but perhaps
the strangest thing happens in the
series yet
it doesn't end in a cheap fashion like
with a transformation or a new character
revelation instead the hook is
narratively driven
sort of suddenly goku awakens outside
the capsule corp totally fine
how did he get there how will he help
his friends tune in next time
episode 33 all right it's next time so
apparently the last episode was the end
of the last arc and this is the start of
a brand new one
it seems like this story does the exact
opposite of super it connects arcs but
not episodes within an arc interestingly
however it's revealed that foo was
successful and that goku is now in a
universe that foo
created as he's hunted down through the
streets of west city that's sort of cool
i guess
that is until i realized that frieza and
mecca cooler are the ones chasing after
him so
hearts shows up and i'm not even
remotely kidding here i didn't recognize
him without his sunglasses apparently
he's a good guy now i like how ultra
instinct is being used here in the
setting also but
yeah mask goku shows up no idea what
that means next
episode episode 34 the animation and
direction in this one is
noticeably different it's not the same
shots over and over again or the same
boring layouts and cuts of animation
there's a different person behind the
wheel of this one and it's abundantly
clear so
this evil goku is using the dark dragon
balls to empower and control frieza and
cooler and then
broly shows up out of nowhere making
loud and annoying noises again
reminding me that yes i am indeed
watching super dragon ball heroes
everyone disappears and we get a new
goal collect all the dragon balls to
make a wish
all the while vegeta's above them about
to fight comber and turles
episode 35 there's again more fighting
in this episode with some
super saiyan rose and super saiyan blue
goku not to mention turtles and cumber
going at it but
the highlight for me has to be the
instances where the series suddenly
shifts as turles encourages vegeta to
try and embrace his darker side
through which we're shown reanimated
versions of iconic scenes from the
original series and for a brief moment i
remembered what it was like to watch
dragon ball and enjoy it in a moment
where i genuinely felt as though
vegeta's character was treated with some
level of intelligence by referring to
his past to inform his present
and i say that totally ignoring how dumb
it looked with the black and blue aura
by the way
but the reason i draw attention to this
at all is because
it made me stop to think having spent
the last year and a half
reading and reviewing some of the best
stories in shonen returning to the
dragon ball franchise by way of super
dragon ball heroes was
a less than satisfying affair i mean
it's sort of like returning to watch
disney by way of the live-action mulan
movie it's trash and it's unanimously
recognized by the majority as such but
even with that in mind this show
while reminding me of what the series
was has planted a few seeds of doubt
dragon ball was my favorite story for
most of my life
and was one that has given me the life
that i have today i wouldn't have a
channel if not for that very series
the colorful and lighthearted characters
as well as the iconic moments throughout
will always hold a special place in my
heart but having watched all of those
episodes of super dragon ball heroes
it's left me wondering does the original
dragon ball hold up after
all these years is it as good as i
remember it to be
or has the last year full of reviewing
the very best shonen has to offer
changed my perception on the series that
started it all for me
so i've got an idea it's been a very
long time since i consistently uploaded
dragon ball content and the early
portion of the series is one of the most
underrated aspects of the story with the
most casual fans never having even seen
it
so seeing as i've reviewed all of dragon
ball gt and dragon ball super
how about i finish this series right
starting next week i totally not mark
i'm returning to dragon ball
to review akira toriyama's worldwide
smash hit
i'll see you there
[Music]
you